[Applaudissements]
six matches je suis ma saison thaïlande
et j'ai senti que vous étiez un tout
petit peu tonglet
oui c'est qu'avec la versa ouais une
chanson way à fleurs durent séduit mais
c'est un petit peu tendu il ya des
noeuds abu aita me wade a touché le
dossard ouais enfin maria bhl je peux
jouer malgré tout c'est ton du ser il
a vu que j'avais pas ça avant non avant
d'annoncer avoir touché non plus hein
oui c'est vrai tu as créé pas bien comme
tout bon
placement un peu
et si vous masse mieux que moi à un
problème
c'est qu' avec cité lot
et
qui fait du bien il fait bien fait du
bien
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tous
vous avez vu de préavis dont de la nuit
autour de vous c'est sa mère il a tenu
un salaire tenu l'hôtel et vieux nice et
boulogne embrasse tous les petits bons
gars franchement benhaim vous ne partez
pas
[Applaudissements]
sinon géraldine manière inadéquate et
non et non ses moi mais vous vous année
où la
chatterie v concept est tout sur moi
pour les vacances en asie des filets
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
l'étude
c'est
j'ai senti que vous étiez un petit peu
tendu
[Rires]
regardez elle tu ne peux pas venir
puisque tu me pas mal avait aucune
autorité sélectionné mais à la nage ou
s'en prennent à moi c'est moi aussi même
si on pouvait y perdure on a fait des
saisons géraldine maillet sénans daniel
malheureusement sera et hewitt mais
prendre l'avion
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est un grand oui
niang
jean-michel
mes potes il habillé comme mes potes
alors il va il est bien à quoi ils
étaient libres au programme j'aime bien
c'est bon tu veux partir tu seras en
thaïlande est membre est toi et moi
torse nu sur un scooter c'est des petits
cadeaux
finalement c'est nous
c'est la chine qui vous a convaincu non
non pas dire à moi je fume jamais depuis
charme il s'applique ici mais vous êtes
fous ces particules inhalées j'avais que
ça arrêtez avec ça je n'ai jamais fumé
de chicha de ma vie ces massages élevé
dans les chichas de temps en temps mais
non monsieur michaud ont pallié
d'enrichir son film la chicha oui ah oui
aussi fabien sur ben oui c'est vrai
c'est comme on peut mettre des slips et
donc avoir de coucougnettes attend
maintenant
alors oui team htc vous n'y allez vous
venez pas
c'en est trop alors on va accueillir
maintenant gilles verdez
[Applaudissements]
ouais
tu fais en
les pays veulent interdire de toute
façon
c'est quoi cette danse non mais j'étais
dans le personnes avec lesquelles perso
le moins d'impôts à main franchement
c'est catastrophique c'est non non c'est
non c'est non point de craquer moins
drôle aussi non c'est moi on à qui
d'autre allez on va accueillir à à de
leurs maux
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c
[Applaudissements]
moi excuse moi + moi
mais tu es emploi comment
as tu me demandes oui au moins deux
shows line ah oui ça c'est un moine
shaolin sa jolie version wii a récemment
de shaolin
2.0 on ne réfléchit pas qu'en thaïlande
une réfléchir dans d'autres pays oui
tu réfléchis là
c'est joli non franchement ça ne me fait
rien qu'ils rangent pas le couleurs de
cet été lors du 10 au 21 salles couleurs
de cet été quand y en a eu jamais bien
voilà moulin et ça va être très sympa et
plutôt toi toujours ton gyrophare dans
le si
ça c'est que lui lui 10 au 21 il est né
en patrouille à miglos sériole appelle
ça des radios
sur la plage tout le monde se pose tout
ça c'est un truc de fou à ce qui est
vrai c'est que je connais le maire non
le maire de mykonos attendez je te
plains cette première session
et aurions évidemment mon bébé oui alors
que l'aisne merde alors yakhi alors ça
c'est que je serai dans tendance mykonos
alors ça se présente très bien j'ai on a
loué une maison très sympa dans le
centre parce qu'on peut tout faire à
pied à sa part que si tu sors ta but où
saâdane a pas de scooter pas de manacor
il ya cinq chambres d'accord une un
petit peu c'était celle qui était prévu
un petit peu isolé avec salle de bain à
part d'accor voilà et après je dirais
que c'est un grand qui boudent de
l'amour
c'est on est tous là dedans enfin un
petit peu des cours
il ya aussi quelques ça oui à nos
réserves non pas pas de ça chez nous
[Applaudissements]
non mais à l'ol de
gbagbo c'est à côté
ouais on va bien rigoler enfin vous êtes
estime arrange surtout c'est que comme
on est on va être prêt à retourner 7j 7
avec 3,8
quand tu sors et tout ça où se croisent
à un tanin careca mais qu'il le ramène
parce qu'on est gentil en scooter ça se
ramène sa machin c'est ça un pépé quoi
on serait super top en croise de temps
en temps pour toi aussi tu prends ton
petit-déjeuner quelqu'un que tu as
j'aime les vêtements désir qui sera plus
là deux heures après c'est fou j'ai un
budget assez l'auberge espagnole et on
trempe sont croissants
mission
moi je vous dis les fonctions de
directrice à digérer certain que j'y
serai pas mal d'étapes ans c'est sûr que
j'y serai pas après la thaïlande ça vous
ferait du bien non non non non non non
non je vais casser des bonbons taillan
tu sais pas
quoi c'est vraiment là circuit la cua la
circuit c'est connaissait alors là
circuit la circuit ces dix jours de
sorties gay où tous les toutes les
boîtes de nuit les piscines tout est
organisé pour des événements gay jusqu'à
7 heures du matin ça sort ça boit tout
ça et elle se déplace elle est dix jours
à barcelone par exemple en juillet a
battu à mort selon lui a battu va pas
être déçu non ces récits de contes
reverra la première fois c'est un peu
douloureux
non merci encore barcelone parce que là
j'ai pas les dates exactes c'est fin
août je travaille ses fesses et fin août
à mykonos donc en fait je suis un
circuit urbain visiblement voilà qui met
les lions de roscoff
[Rires]
j'avais dit cadeau pour toi pour avant
mykonos c'est un petit pipeau eux non
mais c'est vrai et dès que tu seras en
difficulté du souffle comme ça et je
j'apparaîtrai mais non à babouche pas
quand tu passe comme ça à
besoin de quelque chose
j'ai mis ses paroles bien tu veux donne
vraiment je te donne je l'offre à ça me
touche son premier cadeau à 7 ans
est battu à voir comme quoi tout arrive
allez on va cueillir maintenant ah bah
on va cueillir à barbecue est vraiment
très bon très bon bah vous avez mon sens
un petit peu le cousin de européen est
prévu
[Applaudissements]
salut
il faut tout niké je te dis tout de
suite c'est pas on est là on dort 8
heures on se lève
direct dans les frantic looking dans les
lampadaires
amerigo l'est pas je n'ai pas ces cris
bien que ces qui vient est taillé pour
l'instant y'a que mexicaine ou toi et
moi ah ouais vraiment le prix du lait
[Applaudissements]
je ne vais pas sélectionner la serveuse
dans la rose de tunis
[Rires]
avec le chapeau samassa merci tu veux
pas t'asseoir hat est bien là nantes est
bien là bas
tu restes le chef le main en thaïlande
[Applaudissements]
tu soulèves manière que je voulais un je
voulais revenir sur cette question
sachez qu'en thaïlande avec moi les mecs
qui a pas de chef si on est en vacances
on serrait ya pas de toi tu es le chef
tout est pas le chef côté non on n'y
touche chef il n'y a pas de chausser les
bottes pancartes oui non mais je vous le
dis c'est vrai les vacances tu apparais
quelques jours de vacances et moi et pas
de celle qui fait entre couilles
parce que là les deux jouent sans
attaquer mais vous aider ou en thaïlande
d'ici cinq ans
attention à part dont je suis pas tout
le temps la sarre étaient ces deux
maisons capitaux il part en entraînement
de boxe thaï en excursion en scooter à
dans celui qui lui crée duquel et c'est
amusant le ciel
c'est la vraie vie c'est la jungle
[Applaudissements]
exemple
paris c'est pas la porte dauphine
entre lui et je suis pas
[Rires]
énervé
à dix tours de
la fin je montre quoi dimanche
50 secondes
attention c'est chaud sur la voie là tu
vois
[Applaudissements]
comprenez
suivent au classement
les masques
tombent ramon tombera tube aux sombres
vas-y bon c'est
pas mal ah ouais c'est pas vrai ami et
l'émission de
[Applaudissements]
m6 on nomme
producteurs
industries combien
dans la merde bien bien détenir
déclenché dans un appel à l'aide
internationale
toi tu viens porte island maintenir les
planches
sa
directrice la planche une douzaine ya
pas de sa vie mais moi les deux mais non
il n'y a pas de stabilité là allez pas
de piège y a pas que ça
[Applaudissements]
le
c'est bien tu vas césar d'être
annoncée va à ano mais quand je dis plus
jamais ça
je vous explique
[Applaudissements]
je prendrai le ris de me cacher notre
escorte idoine semaine des vacances
d'été normal
vainqueur l'an dernier et après on fera
des concours de planches cassé
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]
ces parkings
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je n'ai rien fait n'a en tous cas
scénario
elle est prête
l'émail
elle va vraiment sapé 1
c'est un débat où vous avez eu mal mais
on vous avait eu mal fou à les retaper
là vous avez gagné vous ai fait mal ou
pas du tout vouloir calmer sa
culpabilité on voulait la paix ah non
alors je vous dis oui mais pas fait mal
du tout le même sens que c'est guinée
leveaux règles et alors ils me voulaient
me taper
officiellement je parle en thaïlande où
on veut aller
[Rires]
à quoi
oh non mais josette
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
ça va je regarde
ici
[Rires]
c'est pas possible
on pas dit là
là
halilhodzic on a le droit de me taper
pour se venger
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
allez
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est ni dans quelle émission
les chroniqueurs et la peine vous êtes
très dur c'est d'ailleurs sa préface on
dit ça
[Applaudissements]
alors fait du gainage à londres les
chéris ça fait mal aux mains non mais
j'en prends plein la gueule
on est où là les siens à paris boulogne
boulogne on est obligés dire qu'est ce
qui à l'avenir on est où là à boulogne
alors c'est pas du tout tapé du couffo
ne paye pas il sait pas vers la salle
matin nom mathieu ici que j'ai pas là
mais voilà il est pas là dedans il a pas
envie c'est que ces jouissons wind parce
que tu sais que ça revient pas ouais
voilà tu devrais payer du coup je note
d'abord l'abcès jeu contre la violence
les gens qui savent pas se battre les
magnifiques me suis un homme j'ai bouclé
ce que tu as toujours bloqué on va
accueillir le dernier le plus beau
benjamin castaldi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est vraiment du mal à
garder
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
pour la taille on
arrête il m'apparaît que
tu veux percer meilleures planches dans
l'affairé tapie et d'extincteurs
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est beau temps
[Applaudissements]
c'est très beau c'est très beau je m'en
sers personne s'est posé une question de
l'éthique mais c'était quoi son
déguisement
combattants en gros ça c'est un libanais
débrouille c'est un homme bien guillaume
non mais la maison qui vient maintenant
j'ose l'équipe d'à ça y est j'ai ma
petite idée je pense à bien vos critères
selon lesquels vous vous basez sur quoi
les gens
je vais vous dire qu'il vient allez je
suis en mesure de vous dire qu'il va
venir en thaïlande ça y est ok ok et je
vais dire à part je voudrais une musique
de suspense il alors le stress musique
de suspense
non c'est non
[Applaudissements]
à la criminelle quatre des suspects
le loup
les lots
ce soit
vous étiez
9,9 à vouloir partir
en thaïlande
tous les jours ouais à fouquette en
thaïlande au foot
on remercie l'office de voyage
certains d'entre vous pour garder
l'incognito là bas
les nous
sont sélectionnés
je dirais partira partira pas
gilles verdez
c'est non
[Musique]
bonne nouvelle
non mais non on attend maintenant le top
va nous retarder
daniel moreau
sinon
elle propre à elle pour pas l'avion
malheureusement et bien sûr
elle restera ici avec sa famille à royan
à montlouis
les vacances de
ne pas prendre l'avion une fois dans ta
vie qu'est ce qui va t'arriver si vous
me donnez
l'on commençait franchement est-ce a dû
recommencer paris
there la main dans ta liens
web on est franchement rallier d'accord
sur rien pourquoi quand même tu serais
capable de venir
s'est pas passé comme ça dans une
ambiance alors ça qui va y avoir du
rythme mais là bas mais non elle va pas
falloir innover bora l'on croit vraiment
qu'il va faire l'entraînement moi je te
l'entraînement de même toute la journée
n'ont
pas envie de venir ou pas et bonjour
lecteurs j'aurais vraiment peur de tout
la peur de quoi moi j'ai peur de tout
même soir même pas le périph alors
et en thaïlande avait un jour on est
parti aux toilettes avec dany dans paris
alo et on devait descendre trois marché
du riz tenir la main
mais ça semble
cdb tard oui à des rats pas rien oui on
ira par
il était
toujours là non plus le soir elle sera
tout va les soirées ça dans sa chambre
en ville parisiens par un crocodile dans
ta chambre et non d'un document c'est
regarder un peu le guide du routard mais
qu'est ce que la foi qui va t'arriver au
pire des cas d'un serpent dans ta
chambre ça sera un sur une super
nouvelle
[Rires]
oui on va dire à quelqu'un
pour une fois qui a donné hier soir dans
sa chambre à coucher nord-isère déconner
fléchir écoute c'est maintenant qu'on
réfléchisse ya pas de réfléchir c'est
maintenant que je vais donner la liste
je dois la donne et je dois donner à
nice ce soir
j'étais spectateur on la place de
personne
alors tu viens ou pas ah oui on allait
oui deux non j'étais mis un trotteur au
dernier moment prendre l'avion en est
avec toi
allégement boulogne sera morte à
boulogne
[Applaudissements]
est progressivement que j'avais d'abord
dans un endroit peu mais c'est
plutôt
moi
[Applaudissements]
cyril par ali zamani peut d'abord leur
mire
l'espagne s'est déjà
l'espagne bat l'espagne ces menaces à
burgos fans c'est non c'est bon sinon
c'est la taille un seul entraînement le
pas pour jouer les très bons c'est non
bon bah c'est gros c'est trop peur c'est
normal oui je t'ai mis non ça y est
c'est fini de coupure mineure contre la
chance que tous ces noms
[Rires]
non j'étais certes on les laisse
on va faire de la moto la non et non je
vais sélectionner au jeu sélectionné
déjà ceux qui sont sélectionnés et après
on prendra une décision tout son sens
pour gilles c'est non c'est non vraiment
c'est oui bah oui
de servir un mec comme ça en thaïlande
mais déjà l'idée lui bloque un petit mot
sur blessure c'est bloqué c'est oui
c'est sûr c'est vraiment spécial et je
sais pas s'il y aura des frais s'il ya
de la bagarre va faire comment
l'épave est abattu mais enfin tu veux
que je te passe en ciseau
le silo
[Applaudissements]
nos vêtements
sont là mais tomba et va faire six
otages et montrer un claquage
ça
bonjour bonjour
un monde clos
[Applaudissements]
soit 30 % et 6 mois
pour l'instant pour l'instant tu vas te
calmes et eu en effet des fougasses
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
incroyable et frère
foot moi bien tu vas revenir là pour
l'instant on se forme était là tu vas
revenir tu vas être une arme à l'état
mais je tenais une arbalète cymbalettes
raymond tu es sélectionné
mais
je vois pas du tout où il sera bon ma
roue arrière direct non mais je rigole
hyères toulon vient va falloir que ça
dure a dit non mais je suis trop chante
je veux pas venir je suis d'accord
c'est quoi dépend des jours dépassons
qu'ovide
géraldine lice c'est non non mais pour
les raisons voilà je vous adore mais
pour les biens chaque guillaume un bagel
c'est mon successeur a entendu sait très
bien que c'est oui
ça commence à prendre forme sachant ce
qu'il est maqué il prend pas un risque
du couac et filles là bas tout ça non
l'entraînement
s'est déjà entraîné avec moi un jour ah
ouais je peux vous dire que c'est une
bête intéressante et le bois pense comme
ça s'est entraîné ces l'aubette j'ai dû
l'arrêter moi même je voulais continuer
je dirais tu donnes pas tous premiers
jours il est plus fort que raymonde et
ton nom c'est pas pareil
et s'accusent la détente horizontale
mais
il sera répond il sera à mes côtés
l'équipe est bonne pour le passé une
bonne nouvelle qui telle qu'elle est
mais novelli
oui il est prêt cwi ouais
[Applaudissements]
d'accord je serai la saison la bagarre
va exactement vous allez ciao ya une
embrouille pu vous avez tous vos amis
dunkerque bat wil après avoir annoncé sa
fille pour l'instant c'est non mais déçu
décidera après mon fils tanger raja
signe benjamin castaldi mandali rageuse
benjamin castaldi pour avantager pour le
moment c'est non
et je vais vous dire pourquoi pourquoi
ces raisons de santé il a la santé très
fragile ah ouais j'ai pas envie qu'on
soit toute la journée en train de
s'occuper de lui si j'ai mal au genou et
j'ai mal aux pieds j'ai mal au coude et
j'ai mal au nez j'ai mal aux yeux et
j'ai mal ou brouillées dans la série
donc là pour l'instant sénat
fragilité fragilité physique
avis mehdi bennani mme on a ça sent ça
passe pas c'est un grand oui non
pourquoi okwari on a besoin de quelqu'un
qui nous prépare l'état critique
pour le repos du guerrier candice heck
tomba on va partir et des petites peurs
des trucs mais si c'est pour l'instant
on a vraiment guillaume kenny médaille
matthieu delormeau qui paraît
aller
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
parce qu'on aura besoin d'un oeil avisé
voilà pour ça que j'ai pas pris benjamin
[Rires]
besoin de quelqu'un qui le soir sans les
choses aiguille oui nocturne nous disent
oui non non non attention carton car
tout ça oui peuvent faire tout et
n'importe quoi
mais c'est vrai le stick la rime
avec les deux là je vais être obligé
d'être tout le temps derrière des deux
chiens fous là non ça y est vous ne
faites pas partie question vous savez
je viens pour vous surveiller donc
maintenant vous êtes intervenants les
missions de la structure où
ces patients matthieu delormeau
c'est un grand oui
mais qui il partira donc en thaïlande
sera composé de raymond guillaume kenny
pédales
matthieu delormeau
clarifie la gare les dents de 5 mokhtar
des cons il est compris à
moi c'est pareil c'est la même personne
du coup baby star mokhtar accouché deux
mois
est-ce qu'on peut ramener des plus sains
alors qui a des copines oui
vraiment vous avez ramené chacun a plus
un américain qui vraiment personne merci
doline elle fait des bonds massage
bottemer personnes
amènent quand même temps sans nourriture
mais bon au sud avec kevin et jason
de bond de 24 ans j'adore la thaïlande
qui vous aime beaucoup ah oui bah non
mais oui mais oui mais non sera quoi non
mais non
balci d'asie
mais non à 6,6 à mais non le choix que
t'as pas encore bien conscience de tes
vacances
tu vas rentrer différents
qu'une la tuerait croyable alors alors
voilà ça c'est bon noski monde il
n'avait plus un c'est qu'on aurait fait
ben ammar et mon guytou kelly maman
ouais et bam nou 2-2 par chambre et
samassa match est retombé à deux pattes
emmerde pas look tard el moctar il va
être dans ma chambre ils marchent ou
samedi qui bat monde à moi
j'ai pu venir c'est vrai que ça part en
contre dès qu'on a dit on pour
l'entraînement
on reste entre eux
alors si je ramène quelqu'un qui m'a
fait une demande lee c'est une personne
qui m'est cher et c'est qu'il faisait
chez une femme qui sait qui vous est
cher qu'une femme 21 ans blonde
c'est ma mère qui
m'a mis baba pour les repas tu pourrais
me prendre mais on va faire sauter donc
ma mère c'est we hate me faire les
courses
alors je réhabilite castaldi
sceptiques réponse avec la carte de
crédit si la panne au day t'inquiète pas
benjamin qui assistent votre mère est
exactement votre assistant de mama
occidentaux n'y a pas d'audience à la
tuque marque pas mais
je tenais est déjà marié maintenant
alors la grande question qui vient
maintenant régis non non non non vous
gilles et
maintenant on a une question c'est
gilbert des
je vais passer parmi vous et vous me
donnerez une réponse oui ou non est ce
que vous voulez que gilles verdez
viennent
tous ceux qui ont été sélectionnés
guillaume
gille malgré ton costume me vincent
lagaf mais la fouille n'a
pas été convaincue c'est un grand nom ta
grande très bon moi si je le fais pour
ta santé ça va aller vite ça va aller
très très vite là bas il va y avoir
plein d'activités c'est un grand nom
pour la santé de notre absenté des mecs
- j'en ai rien à [ __ ] venez tous si
vous bien mais ça va envoyer dix la
force tranquille et la sérénité je dis
oui à
ces télés
[Applaudissements]
c'est elle qu'on les a mis un terrain
réponse pas quel point on s'aime et ce
qu'il dit
[Applaudissements]
c'est quel point je t'aime et on est
amis et qu'elles pourront partager les
mêmes points de vue oui on pourra
discuter ensemble c'est un grand nom
de la lucidité moi je suis obligé de
suivre avec mes camarades et je vais te
dire également non pas ça qu'on veut ça
va vite ça qu'on veut
j'espère que tu pars d'un petit peu de
langues étrangères non nine nice
donc à ramasse n'aviez nadal oncle
les yeux la faim dans sa tombe et tu
vois ta barbichette
tu crois tu as barbichette et des
claquettes et petites aventures d'être
déçus du coût de la vie de tous de quoi
mais pas le vôtre des traces ici sa
mâture voix contre trip quadruples sécu
de série le bataillon mais combien allez
vous évoquer l'économie que vous l aimez
beaucoup j'attends un signe de route il
peut être est ce le mans series la verra
si vous voulez vous dire je vous aime
on ne savait pas qu'elle
savait pas combien je m'appelle attendez
attendez attendez je vous aime ta gueule
d'ailleurs
juste les chéris petite précision parce
que je crois que là ya bien un petit
problème bienvenus oui oui un petit
quiproquo
vous pensez en fait que c'est moi qui
vais payer l'intégralité
c'est ce que vous savez quoi mais non
frais là mais non chacun avec son
personnage mais les mecs je vous ai dit
alors il n'y a pas de chef un jeu rapide
de venir
en fait vous êtes un génie vous êtes en
train de nous donner l'autorisation de
partir en vacances où on veut avec notre
argent
ces ploucs r oui alors maintenant on
m'avait cette d'année et bien oui je
pourrais vider mon pel pour vous tenir
la main merci c'est bon vraiment je
travaille
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
en fait on perd et moi
et moi je ne prends pas l'avion
l'avion s'appelle
valérie vous suivrez au bout du monde
madame jamais un ami jamais les tensions
d'argent qui supporte pas
qu'elle est à moi je suis un peu ric rac
en ce moment merci que mais je vous
propose de me l'offrir
l'ag ordinaire les gars c'est un test
je voulais voir vraiment ce qu'ils
étaient motivés qui m'aimait bien score
vrai la dre la 2 je vous invite
mais non maintenant je n'invite plus que
guillaume benhaim castaldi qui n'y en a
plus droit de faire des vénitiens
[Applaudissements]
avec la lazio naples orateurs j'ai vu
chez verizon c'est ma vie
plus vous pourrez visage hagard
pétersbourg vous avez dit que c'était
pas cher c'est 500 euros la semaine tout
compris ces lasers et on
s'aime entraînements c'est leur nom
est-ce que je vais pas les mettre ça va
être compliqué merci à vous allez payer
l'avion aussi maintenant on va payer on
va donner quelque chose on n'est pas des
crevards